Yeah that. The deep ecology idea that we're just part of the fabric of life. With every other living thing.
And that the despair we feel for the future of the planet is the spear of all life forms on the earth.
So the ritual involves expressing that the spear. And in. Creating him.
Selecting an item of landscape over a species with something to represent in the council of all beings.
And then you make a mass and then you come to the council as that creature or. Item of landscape.
And you find voice to speak for it. And this is a very powerful ritual.
It's a very powerful bonding experience for people who are involved in. Rainforest action or.
You know action from the environment. And it's also very powerful it giving people voice like.
They found the confidence in the voice to speak what they really are concerned about. So this.
This particular ritual is. Kind of essential to the work that john slade's been doing in the rainforest life.
Information center and the rainforest the. Action groups around the stranger who did.
Defending the environment the people who have committed their lives. To being on the front line.
For the environment and. Only possible. In this theory.
Right that it was born here because they were a sufficient concentration of people committed to developing these works.
In their life.
So light a manifestation more current is like conflict resolution
and negotiation skills have become a major currency up here. And people will and. The new settlers in syria.
Do this very well. And it's taking the shape of it and then you will.
A conference called the hot politics conference where social activists come together and discuss.
What's been happening in their lives. You know. Particularly if they. Being in despair and burnout. Take.
You have to find you hot. Working together and talk about techniques. Of creating. Nonviolent social action.
The challenge is enormous. Big changes are coming and big changes are going to be made.
How to do this nonviolently how to create say. Compassionate and. Culturally rich community.
Is the challenge of the times. And i see it happening here. Well the time i worked in melbourne and sydney.
I did not see it. I didn't see it expressing itself in community the west see it happening on the north coast.
Where you. River. The river. Well. Not all of the turnings of the. Not all parts of the queerest dreams. Proficiency.
Properties fruit. You know. And some of the fruit turned sour on us and. One of the observations i have about the.
The drug scene was that. It was part of the queerest dream that drugs were a liberation.
We were greatly influenced by the. Timothy leary huxley. Stuff about doorways to perception that would open your mind.
We're about expanded awareness. And i'm quite clear that the.
Aquarius festival wouldn't have happened without the influence of marijuana
or an illicit gens i mean that was one of the cultural stimulants that opened them on still two hundred years.
When it was combined with the necessities of economics and then the problem of newman not being able to have a gate
and be discriminating about the people who were coming in and camping on. You know i'm a strong enough to say no.
We had a number of things happening. You know. We could. Look back and say that.
Marijuana as a community second has lots of downsides. We can say with what happened was that.
People smoke a lot of marijuana the group themselves.
So it was always really a vial of a lot of police will blew their minds away with marijuana.
Because it got stronger and stronger i mean i was doing selective breeding and testing it themselves or it.
Results in a lot of liturgy in the community. We have lots of people who have ideas about how things would happen.
But very little action very little people are able to actually bring it all together. Sit down and make have a meeting.
That's clear enough to make agreements. Marijuana does not assist meetings.
A lot of the early troubles we had with meetings was that people were stunned when they came to them.
They weren't responsible what they're saying.
They unloaded stuff and they couldn't hear marijuana stops people from hearing. What other people have got to say.
And then there was the market side of marijuana that.
The good thing about it was that it would provide a means of income in to build lots of houses in the state area there
are lots of grass castles in the city. It's true to say. It provided people with income.
And allowed them to lift themselves out of poverty.
And to prove the conditions of the family but the other side of that was that introduced. The now eighty.
People got easy money and. So they dismissed. The idealism of the queer in dreams as a relevant.
What the real world is about is making money. Mate. And doing deals and being smart about the drug deals. So we had a.
What's called the deal ocracy the people who are smart at selling drugs.
Thought themselves to be superior and apart from what was going to else was going on.
There is associate that with these paranoia. None of these things make them. Pull community. It's a community.
So in new old days you know. You should be able to grow. Remember when had you gotten pets and to be safe. Not now.
People have been known to being busted people coming in with guns and stealing marijuana.
Patches and was kind of stuff. Whole communities. Fall apart because.
The growers afford what amongst themselves on the community. And had such a siege mentality. They didn't want business.
What this. You know that the community ceased to work as a community. It was just a drug running cooperative.
So there are lots of downsides. And then we had the problem of. Human being to open. So that.
During the eighty's when they ran the government governments or in australia began closing down mental hospitals
and putting.
Patients on the road and saying community should look up look after them the family should look after them.
What we got was a policeman all went straight to the saying i want to go to newman.
And women being inundated with the walking wounded. And i can say. The addicted. I remember in the late seventy's.
A group of. Sixteen year old alcoholics from the western suburbs of new haven.
Descended on women and expected to be looked after. Oh sorry. I remember in the late. Member in the late eighty's.
The late seventy's. A group of sixteen year old seventy year old.
Alcoholics from the western suburbs of sydney descended on human.
And one of them looked up and this was the new age and the new age would look after people like them.
Would tolerate their behavior. And their behavior. Was disgusting. They were drunk most of the time. And abusive.
And richard lee. Dissolute. And proud of it. They saw themselves as being punks who were there to shock.
We old aquarians into a new sense of reality. And why did. We were shocked when reported.
But were unable to do anything about it and that became the model for people to follow. I mean.
One of those guys did now. Another one's on a med pension brains.
These were desperate cases people who wanted to be did this is total neil ism. We're talking about the future.
And suddenly we have to deal with needless. And you have no future. And on top of that. That. You know.
The rejects the. The walking wounded who arrived in town from. The closed.
Mental hospitals who are expected to be look i looked up. I remember the case of them and turn straight on and.
You came to now. The town and. He was very black. He was about five foot four.
Tall and five foot four across the shoulders. And when he got some alcohol in him he would. Hangry. And violent.
He was looked after by the community. He was fit for free in the cafe and i asked to do some shoes.
Just sweep in the would happily contribute to that he was you know sober he was a really nice guy to talk to the
community. But when drunk he put his fist through the plate glass window of the rainbow cafe one night.
And another cation he. Two women. And one night had a ton of fools. And the next day you sleeping off he's. Alcoholic.
Fathers in the tomato sauce and. Some guys coming to town from town of all fools.
Approached the tomato sauce put bella gloves on the face and pulled out simple b. From forty to seventy theorem.
Cuts and beat the guy up we do about the legs. The limb no it was not.
This is bad news when you community has been dealing with these but what other. Expression was there.
I heard that this guy left town shortly after that he did get the new seeds
and i heard that he was one of the deaths in custody.
But there was like it was like the situation was if you can survive in human you can't survive anyway. You know.
More compassion more tolerance in even than any other community i've been to. And it was much the abused.
So what's happened more recently. Is like the street drug scene. Had got very.
I mean it's being attended to now but for a while there it got very bad. Smith moved in i couldn't imagine.
Its make would come to him and we always thought. In the seventy's that it required.
More money than that but of course marijuana generated. Its own income.
Its own drug trade so there was an exchange people would bring back an exchange for marijuana and.
Nimbin became a holiday resort for. Junkies. Right. If you're living in the back streets of.
You know that you and you had a habit.
You heard about this wonderful place we can get any drug you want within ten minutes in when i go for holy name and so.
Newman developed its own hard drug scene and. This. This makes.
In another sense this is like newman being a prophetic community it's only acting at what's happening in other.
Other cities but doing it much more blatantly and much more upfront. Than anywhere else. It's true.
But newman only has one main street and. The smack scene is right smack in the middle of it and.
Visitors coming to him and don't see the new age optimism the rainbow power company. What they see as work down.
People. No light in their eyes or to know that is in the future and. It's kind of got. Institutionalized.
You know like. There's sufficient concentration to have its own mores in its own defense. Not easily moved.
Not easily hidden and. Not a great advertisement for anyone. No more sense of failure from nimbin.
Community trying to deal with the effect of drugs and i think.
I agree with what i said about this the problem is the law. Prohibition creates the problem.
If marijuana and heroin were available. Legally and.
Controlled in the same way as the supply of alcohol and cigarette in the containers controlled.
We wouldn't have the market situation we wouldn't have the economy that supports the scene and.
All the downside of it would be removed. It could be treated it could be addressed as a community problem.
But while we have a this is covert. There's no way you can bring the forces of light onto it you know like. You.
You can't have active programs. You. You can't create. A community. Rehabilitation program.
That's going to work because the culture of the. Addiction is self-supporting you know. Anyway. It's a nutty problem.
I think. I've got more hope than him and i'll do something creative about it than anywhere else. But it's like.
It's one of the things that newman and hear it from aquarius that has its dockside set aside and talking
and share this. Let me talk about this other aspect of nimbin. That. When we were organizing the queerest festival.
We heard this rumor that was coming from the aboriginal community.
In melbourne of all places that nimbin had a coup supported. And it was the valley had been cursed.
It was said that they'd been a message to the and.
And i could have been put on by the aboriginal people that nothing would ever prosper. That happened in that valley.
To somehow the kiss was lifted. So i was really interested to find out about this it was part of the myth making.
The festival. And i went chasing.
Every zone leaders in the am searching them out to find out what they knew about it and i came to the nothing.
You know. I mean. Uncle lisle and. Who is the average loner at the time. And he knew nothing about it or if you did.
He was unwilling to talk about it. But the woods that was said.
Were when i asked him about his spiritual issues when i got back with christian. Woods right.
So my feeling was a bunch of young people have been so effectively. Christianized.
That they didn't know the story anymore. If it wasn't immediately available. So we went into the festival. With it.
Hanging over us and. A couple of years and. In about nine hundred seventy seven. I had an opportunity to visit.
Kath walker. Stradbroke on. And it was. We had a remarkable night. With catherine and her camp fire.
Which she showed us some of her sherman. Abilities sherman palace and of poetry.
And the madness and all that kind of stuff of on those nights.
And in the course i told her story of nim and what was happening there.
And she expressed interest in finding it more and i was interested if i have the aboriginal story.
So i invited cat who had come to him and. Stay with us for a while and she did.
And she stayed with a friend and at the end of a week stay. I went to see you. And i say well what do you think.
What do you know. You see that she is feeling with that newman. Was my initiation ground. The.
Very strong country that. This is not good for women. So it's not a place where women are going to prosper.
So i take that into account. And the other thing. Other thing about it. Is that.
It's a place where people come to learn. Young men coming through initiation. And if you stay too long.
You don't get the initiation if you don't learn. And move on then you turn to stone.
And i think that the rocks will take the energy back that take the teaching. Back and you'll be become. Region. And.
I got this misleads.
Nine hundred seventy seven the battle of trainee creek with noni seventy eight and i was like i felt.
Developed or any crick for me was like. As much as i could do in community organization. I mean i got.
What i wanted the community was strong enough. You know. It was working as a community and. I did.
Fictive really been marginalized by my. Radical stand on the first fight. So that any time i try to do anything.
You know i had a chorus of voices saying shut up. Stop. Don't do anything more you cause too much trouble.
I begin to realize that my initiation was. It was time for me to move on. So those words had a personal meaning for me.
But i also observe them in him and i see that. Part of the drug problem in nimbin is young people.
Because that the drug market the drug dealers. Namely usually. Typically people selling drugs the tourist.
Typically nineteen eighteen year olds who lack. Appropriate initiation. They path the man who is. Off the riles.
And it needs. Stronger. Initiation. To bring them in line. Also. Is that when you.
If this is forty thousand years old this wisdom. About this country. And if you ignore it you do so at the peril.
And it's as if. If you. Muck around with that kind of energy. It has its own eighty eighty s you know so what was.
Was that positive thing for learning. Turns in on itself. And then the shadows. Reveal themselves.
So you know since then there's an e. Meter is a metaphor. In here about. The social problems and even the drug problem.
Is being generated. Being. The shadow of the korean dream. Because somehow the land is being abused. Somehow.
Not enough respect. Is being taken of the energy that. That bellina here and lee has. So. Naman. It's my.
Mother of joy mother of this be. It broke my heart. It broke it open. Yeah.